good afternoon everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today is SCP 3209 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures personnel interacting with
populations of SCP 3209 are to wear
liquid crystal active shutter glasses
operating at or above 60 Hertz wild
specimens of SCP 3209 are to be captured
and relocated to an on-site lepidopteran
monasteries keeping SCP 3209 populations
are to be closely monitored for
specimens escaping into the wild
description SCP 3209 Savini ax ax SETI
ax is an anomalous species of butterfly
which preys upon interest an SCP 3209
specimen feeds by perching on the nose
of its target and rapidly fluttering its
wings in front of their eyes affected
animals become lethargic and unmotivated
eventually dying of starvation sapient
beings exhibit a more complex set of
symptoms when exposed to SCP 3209 the
primary effect is permanent loss of
interest in a hobby or topic examples of
interests lost to do to SCP 3209 include
card games poetry science fiction films
and golf frequent exposure to SCP 3209
causes chronic anhedonia and apathy as
most of the symptoms of exposure are
nearly indistinguishable from dysthymia
attempts to locate wild populations of
Savini acedia have primarily focused on
tracking down reports of rainbow winged
butterflies in severe cases individuals
continuously exposed to SCP 3209 may be
identified among patients and
psychiatric care facilities such
patients typically have no prior history
or behavioral incidents live outside of
cities at
hospitalized following suicide attempts
which failed due to their lack of
motivation
addendum 32 or 9.1 field reports of
agent bar tell the ethics committee has
indefinitely postponed actions against
monasteries in and around Nepal an
unknown number of which may be
maintaining populations of Savini acedia
in secret internal discussions center
around the testimony of field agent
Aaron Bartel who was assigned to
identify and investigate monasteries
involved February 11th
2018 might have a lead an ex-monk in
PNAU d with severely disabling apathy
can't even get out of bed probably a
straightforward case of depression but
his nickname caught my eye
apparently people call him the butterfly
man
February 16 2018 met the butterfly man
real name Rajeev Sakia couldn't get a
statement from him he had no interest in
conversing as far as I can tell he has
no interest in anything order lined
vegetative I did obtain the name of his
former monastery from one of the
neighbors taking care of him Tara car
Goomba located in a valley a few
kilometers east of here hoping this
doesn't turn out to be one more dead end
I haven't been home and what four months
February 18th
2018 turgor Goomba is beautiful it's
surrounded by Persian silk trees the
ones studded with pink flowers the
monastery itself is an arrangement of
pale stone buildings around a courtyard
the buildings are connected by Colin
odds painted in rich hues mostly red and
gold at a guess I'd say the place is
three or four centuries old and to think
I almost took a desk job
February 19th 2018 the monks weren't
thrilled about my liquid crystal glasses
cameras are banned here not sure whether
due to religious beliefs or more
practical concerns they spent a few
minutes looking over the glasses before
returning them conveniently they didn't
bother to inspect my books which contain
a small arsenal of surveillance
equipment I don't think they were
feigning ignorance about the glasses if
they're not using active shuttering how
are they protecting themselves February
20th 2018 blindfolds I've only caught a
few glimpses of blindfolded monks but
I'm sure of it somehow they're doing all
the work caring for these butterflies by
sound and touch alone the caretakers
might not even know what they're dealing
with I've been watching out for any
monks behaving unusually but nothing so
far
whatever SCP 3209 is being used for must
be pretty limited there might be only a
handful of monks here aware of its
effects February 21st 2018 first
sighting of Savini Isetta
not hard to find they're kept in a small
glass roofed conservatory built against
the southern wall fairly small
population from what I could see maybe
three dozen or so hid some cameras and a
few nearby bushes to keep an eye on
things next morning four men with
blindfolds visited the conservatory I
want it on record that I have never been
wrong about anything ever
February 23rd 2018 inadvertedly exposed
myself to SCP 3209 woke up open my eyes
and the little [ __ ] was perched right
on my nose shimmer and it swings got me
before I can look away when I regained
focus it was gone
must have zipped right out of there as
soon as it was full from now on well
wear glasses to bed need to figure out
how it got in my room maybe they'd have
me thrown out if the butterfly returned
hungry maybe I'm after any excuse to
frame my mistake as a good thing I keep
getting distracted trying to figure out
what it took from me reviewing all my
hobbies these are a few of my favourite
things etc what's missing what don't I
care about anymore February 24th 2018
just notice the carpets in the prayer
hall they're full of butterflies every
single pattern every border design the
monks here meditate on their knees with
their heads bowed the whole time they're
staring at butterflies
I've been looking at this place all
wrong forest for the trees I haven't
seen any out of place behavior because
this whole place is about SCP 3209
they're all in on it February 26th 2018
I was right
late late last night the Savini acedia
were transferred in a box from the
conservatory to the prayer hall all of
the monks gathered inside the hall no
guests allowed my cameras couldn't get a
clear visual due to poor lighting there
was only a dim flickering glow cast by
floating candles in frosted glass bowls
audio came through just fine though each
monk recited a different phrase over and
over quote longing for my childhood home
quote world politics quote the cuteness
of dogs quote showtunes for getting
stuck in my head it was like a
confessional the ritual lasted roughly
half an hour when it was over they
returned the butterflies to the
conservatory and went to bed
February 28th 2018 I've been thinking a
lot these past few days
reflecting everything about this place
encourages it the windows at the ends of
corridors neatly trimmed grass in the
courtyard the flickering candles there's
a kind of stillness here that gets
inside to you I tend to think of myself
as an impartial observer the foundation
concerns itself with facts and facts do
not depend on perspectives I'm starting
to wonder whether that was naive
I knew the facts of monastic life here
perfectly but until two days ago I
failed to grasp their impact facts
monasteries like this one strive for
three mental states a mob ha non
delusion at visa non hatred and a lapa
non-attachment emotional ties to worldly
matters are considered poisonous impact
this is only because of my cultural
biases that sa p30 to9 appears harmful
where is the line between apathy and
Aloha is Rajiv sakya victim or has the
approach Dhin lightened my instinct is
to recommend capture of all cultivated
populations of Savini ascetic and
administration of amnestics to everyone
involved it will be simpler cleaner it
would also be an inexcusable mistake
these populations are already contained
they pose no threat to civilians
we have no justification to destroy
centuries of tradition and history that
have developed at monasteries like
turgor gamba if we erase every part of
human culture capable of harm will
anything be left March 5th 2018
got home today I'm still adjusting to
how much warmer it is here my son was so
excited to have me back he's been making
all these little finger paintings I
didn't care about them I didn't care
about anything he said or did
I've always been overjoyed to see him
after a long trip no matter how hard I
try I cannot find that feeling now my
son is only four years old and I've lost
interest in him that's what a CP 3209
took from me I stand by my previous
statements okay that about does it for
today thank you all for listening and
you were all dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bessette Desmond Hoskins and
Gaza berry thank you all very much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos and some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you
[Music]